welcome everybody welcome to a stereo
planning my name is Mark Carr Gomm
chairing the meeting this evening right
the procedure for this evening first of
all there as I'm not aware of any
firearms are being scheduled so if there
isn't a along then please if you can
make your way out down by the side of
the pub the windmill into the car park
there and we'll meet outside there thank
you please note this is a planning
meeting with public participation not a
public meeting so only persons
registered to speak will be allowed to
do so during the proceedings this
meeting is being webcast so if you don't
wish to be shown on that please let an
officer know at the appropriate time for
our speakers the scene Thank You Stan if
you said a little away away from the
microphone to speak clearly you won't
get the unfortunate breakup which we
often experience so just a few say six
or eight inches away and then to speak
clearly on that you'll be fine right the
sequence of events this evening are as
follows for each application I'll
introduce the item then the both
supported by the case officer who will
give it an hour for a description town
and parish counselors were allowed to
speak for three minutes
members of the public objecting or
allowed to speak for up to three minutes
the applicant allowed too big to speak
for a measure of time either three or
six minutes I will give a 30-second
warning for time up ward members will
then be allowed to speak for up to a
maximum of five minutes at all stage as
members of the committee are able to
question and speakers and ask questions
following that there we go to a
technical discussion with the officer on
any issues have been raised during the
meeting then into a debate and then a
vote all this is detailed in the notes
in front of you there is a an update
sheet late-breaking items on there
members I think if you've had an
opportunity to read that could I ask all
phones to either turned off or to silent
please for the duration of the meeting
appreciate that thank you
now I'm going to ask the officers to
this evening to introduce themselves
starting from
right I'm banks from committee services
Ross chambers legal services Richard
Gardiner planning manager Eddie wrench
senior planner
thank you so now I'll start the meeting
apologies for absence journal have
apologies from counsel of Audrey and
apologies from counsel Norton for whom
councillor fielding is substituting
thank you
declarations of interest members are
there any declarations interested
Richardson Thank You chair am I to know
517 every zero one eight seven five ful
I did receive a call from a neighbor who
wanted to discuss the application we
didn't discuss it in any depth and I am
here with an open mind I thought I'd
bring that to your attention okay thank
you any other declarations members right
minutes of meeting please appreciate
that I was only there for the meeting on
the 6th of September are members happy
for me to sign those minutes for the
signal and also the 27th of September
agreed I'll sign those after the meeting
ok thank you very much all right well
let's move into the upload gender this
evening them the first item on the
agenda has been withdrawn and this is 17
/ 0 0 676 full
land east of Westholme Road Biddeford on
Aven so we're moving straight on to our
next application which is 17 - Oh 187
5/4 61 ship stern road and the
presenting officer is Eddie Thank You
chair the application site is located
when the built-up area boundary of
struck on Aven is accessed off the ships
and Road the proposal is for the
demolition of a block of 12 flats and
the replacement with 12 dwellings the
western end of the site lies within the
conservation area and abuts the tramway
further to the west as shown here so
this is the tramway here annex of the
ship's Tureaud this is an aerial photo
of the site from the West
showing the surrounding built form the
existing block of flats is located here
and there is also some detached garages
to the rear which would also be
demolished to make way for the
development this plan shows the proposed
layer of the 12 darlings
which would replace the single block of
12 flats would come into line with our
Ashley Court towards the north to the
rear of the site this side shows the
existing and proposed elevations from
ships term road so the bottom slot path
of the slide is the existing block of
flats as it stands today and the north
is the proposed site this slide shows
the proposed elevations of the western
buildings including that from the
tramway so from the tramway the top half
of the slide would be the view these are
the front and rear elevations of the
three dwellings at the center of the
site this photo is from the ship Stone
Road and shows the existing blocks of a
flat in the center and the surrounding
residential development going down ship
Stern Road towards the bridge this show
photo shows the proposed to that access
location adjacent to number 67 ship
Stone Road
just for clarity the hedge would be
removed and the access would be located
around here this photo shows the
existing access to the site and jacent
and number 61
on the right hand side this is the rear
of the site where the existing garrick
is shown on the right which also to be
demolished
this shows the rear elevation of number
61 a the existing boundary wall which
would be retained and the existing
access in the
this is the current view from the
tramway this is the view from the
neighboring developments also from the
tramway so the proposed development
would be the other side of these trees
finally this is another aerial view of
the site this time from the east showing
the ship Stone Road at the front and the
tramway to the rear so this is the ship
Stone Road the tramway runs along here
and then the Sports Center is located
that way and further beyond is the avon
river updates include an updated
representation from the lead local flood
authority of no objection an updated
recommendation further details of the
POS contributions five additional
conditions and two corrections chairman
the recommendation is to grow
information subject to the completion of
the section 106 the 15 conditions
outlined on page 43 and the five
additional conditions on the update
sheet thank you thank you our first
speaker this evening is Catherine
Etheridge Catherine would you like to
come up to the desk please
please in your own time when you're
ready just press the button at the
bottom and then you have two or three
minutes that's fine thank you okay okay
okay so good evening my name is
Catherine a fridge I'm owner of 61 a
trypsin Road as I've shown some nice
photos and I want to speak this evening
an objection to the developments overall
we are supportive and we have been of
any development improving that area
however because that development is
biased completely on to the southern
boundary line for our property there are
a couple of aspects which really affect
us negatively so I quite like the
committee to consider just two issues
and recommendations please leave them
so our first and main issue it relates
to the row of garages with the
additional flat above them which sits
about halfway down our garden
this is no place to two-story structure
about seven and a half meters high
whereas currently it's five and a half
meters onto our boundary line so
increased it by two meters
and brought it three meters in which
that was added postal consultation phase
where there was just a single-story
garage quite sensitively setback from
that boundary this contravenes to
Stratford extending home guidance as
well as policies to CS 9 in CS 20 and
has a much worse impact on the current
flats do have today or view from the
rear of our property there's a few other
aspects which have one to expand on it
is within the 45 degree minimum display
from all our habitation window so it's
within our eyeline now the 17 meter
separation from Maori is significantly
less than the planning guidance of a
minimum spacing of 21 metres and it will
cast shadows in excess of 16 metres
across our property blocking light from
for the bottom third of our garden for
most of the day and casts in a shadow
with the full length and width of our
garden including the rear seating area
after late afternoon and early evening
it substantially affects us in terms of
overbearing and mainly reduction of
sunlight and is categorically worse than
the existing flats in terms of other
developments which should be submitted
in the locality if we look at a report
and two growing news and previous
submission by Churchill residential
they're all set that respectively form
the boundaries minimizing overshadowing
and overbearing of existing gardens as
well as houses so I'd like the committee
to consider and support a recommendation
of either reverting to a single-story
garage up to the boundary line again we
know that be slightly worse but nowhere
near as always what we're looking at
here before
actually if a two-storey set structure
is essential to actually set it back
much further than it is today so today
it's about three meters it would need to
be in excess of five meters so the
photos you can see they're three o'clock
on Sunday afternoon where the actual
line comes across a garden now it's
October so we're in August that would be
halfway across the garden if you now add
2 meters 3 meters in words it will
completely obliterate with that garden
4/3 the second point has to stop you
time fight I didn't give you a 30-second
warning I do apologize can you just
please just do a wrap-up on that what do
you want to say them please thank you
yes so I'd like to recommend that this
the garage is moved to a one-story
building or two storeys 5 metre setback
okay
can I have my one further point thank
you and the second action was the rear
of the property in line with ours where
the decking is that the raised one point
one meter flood right and we'd like to
recommend that that is reduced the
ground-level height because there was no
necess necessity for that to be there
thank you very much I apologize for not
giving you the warning right before we
leave are there any questions you'd like
to ask
Kathi burns good evening just checking
the distance from the your property to
the to the garages is the same except
that they're two stories they are closer
what I'm saying is that the the light
from the garage is not has no effect on
your garden so the light from the garage
will have
fact on the garden but if it was stuck
to a single story we would kind of set
up a circle can security mm-hmm thank
you
and the 70 meters you mentioned can you
just define which bit of policy you're
talking about there for me please
so what will stand from readings at a 45
meter a 45 angles for hey that you need
to have a 21 litres distance now that
just means that it's more in our
eyesight I don't see that as the major
overwriting feature that we issue we've
got it in order sunlight where it's
coming from
okay thank you and do you want to just
clarify the particular point now or do
you wanna leave it to technical
questions just a point regarding the 21
meters that is where you're looking at
two windows that face each other so two
properties are backed back it doesn't
apply when we're looking at daylight and
some nights which is what the 45 degree
test is concerned with but it does apply
when we're looking at privacy thank you
and everything else ended much better
than a visual
I'm like I was gonna make a point that
I'm actually follows on from that I was
a little unclear about the answer we had
for cancer Barnes's question it's
something i've noted for asking for
officers technical given they've just
given a technical do you think we could
follow up and have that now yeah let's
do it quickly that was over there once
sorted out before we got the the
positioning and me courage from the
garage stars if we go to do it in the
technical issue we can't ask the lady
any questions afterwards if we know now
then it's a little bit that's what we're
gonna do now that's what we gonna do you
just point out one of the corrections on
the update she where where i think the
good lady was talking about 70 meters
that is actually a correction because it
should be 21 anyway so basically what
we're talking about for show you on here
from the nearest point of 61 a's
extension to the nearest point of the
garage is 21 meters and the existing
building is further back in and is 7
meters less than that so 14 meters is
the distance from the closest
so that's the existing the this one
unfortunately doesn't show the
experience this is where I am here this
is the ladies house there is an
extension to the rear now and from the
same point to this point here is 14
meters and from the same point to where
the new structure is although it's close
to the boundary is 21 meters so it's a
further slightly around here the height
difference yeah this one is five point
five meters high with a flat and the
ridge right there is less if you look
see
so is it ready I think the lady is
talking about removing this decking area
and having it step straight out onto the
ground floor level rather than have in
that screen as a preference choice
although officers are satisfied but you
know that would counter overlooking
could i clarify on what I'm recommending
that be okay I see Council Joe's house
which is first can you clarify that's
what you're doing thank you yes there
was a consideration and modified to the
plans with the screening put up what we
see there so we don't say proposal is
Nicholson
welcome this not handed yes John Gibson
and Mike Briggs
right in your own timeless Thank You
children
just to introducing we are you make sure
you know me I think Liz Nicholson from
Stan's gate planning but Richard Koontz
with me from Becker architects and he's
going to talk to you in a minute about
the type of work his company is
currently involved with and how this
scheme has evolved we have also got Mike
Briggs with us he's from HR Wallingford
which is an independent civil
engineering and environmental hydraulics
organization they've supported the
Environment Agency and other key clients
he set national flood risk and drainage
policies they've prepared much of the
current UK guidance on suds and drainage
systems for new developments including
original and the recently updated suds
manual so turning to this application it
ships to the road I would like you to
know that Eddy wrench has been proactive
helpful and professional in all dealings
we've had with him a pre-application
stage under the application process
we've met with local councillors and
we've held a public exhibition at the
Swans nest hotel the key issue on this
site has always been to find the best
design and the best engineering
solutions and you've seen that the
solutions are inextricably linked within
these proposals the replacement of the
existing block of flats with 12 new
dwellings will be a great improvement in
the street scene a little be a drainage
solution that will provide betterment
and thus reduce the level of flood risk
not just for this site but also for
London property near the site so I'll
hand you over to Richard and he can talk
to you about the design chairman thank
you would you put some CEO of micro
architects and deferments specializes in
fed motivation
I sit on the RBA's flood policy team and
also number 10 as part of rest core
cities advisory group in the mass spec a
we've been charged with a piece of work
by Defra
the Environment Agency HCA the insurance
sector d CLG have all been involved in
this project and the live project
posits that we can no longer hold alt
right and so life public long-term
initiatives for flood risk environments
is how in many brownfield sites as we
have across the country how can we live
with water and keep our population safe
so this project is actually quite
significant just on a local standard but
also at a national level so this project
is designed to follow the best practice
of that guidance within the live project
but in power of the arab air about to
pass a new white paper to government
looking for higher building standards
and that's also being championed by
syria as well
so why is this in project important well
if anybody knows our work and all of its
on the TV so the amphibious house or the
UK's first floating house now the
downside of those projects are there for
wealthy individuals and therefore the
insurances and the mortgages that come
with those are individually wealthy
people the significance of this project
in particular is that it's for a
multi-unit housing scheme it is going to
be designed to a very very high quality
material 30 seconds plays and built to
the highest standards so if the
committee are mindful to grant this
development it will follow best practice
procedures in terms of architecture will
follow and execute the best materials
it's gone through a monthly consultation
process in support from the Environment
Agency in terms of the overlooking
issues we are mindful that those have
been carefully considered and we hope
that you give this huge consideration
and your support thank your time thank
you very much
yes I'm sure there are a third law but
I'm a personal perspective I think the
flooding aspect is very interesting
there are a few questions I would like
to ask on that particular point because
this is a very relevant to many
communities today obviously there's a
few issues also that have been raised by
our people speaker
Catholicism thank you I don't know who
wanted to take this my first those two
points on two arrays the first of all is
the evolution of that garage block we've
this inference that it was single-story
now it's double storey so if you can
give me some idea of how that's
developed and why and also these flood
measures the tanking it certainly need
to me who incident I used to live in the
Ashley court development I'm not aware
that that was tanking I'm not aware it
was raised I don't want to understand
why it needs to be raised in this
instance was it seems unnecessary okay
so the first question is probably worth
if people have access to the planning
drawings but the existing buildings in
terms of the positions of the windows
and those proposed for the garage block
natural window locations are in exactly
the same position as those existing so
that in terms of overlooking issues it's
the same we haven't brought there's any
further forward or or any distance so
that element I think is is is is a void
point in terms of the book and science
and scale were currently the building
that is against that it's a three-story
building you can see from this elevation
which has no windows in it it's a
single-story plus a gable so it's not
two storey building there will be it is
close to the boundary that's absolutely
true but as to whether it presents any
harm to the neighbor
I think it's within the permissible
parameters of planning that's a very
large garden and we are convinced that
it has no detrimental harm and then so
your second point regarding so it's not
actually tanking the proposition that
you're looking at today so you've got an
existing building with an existing
footprint what we've designed is the
replacement I'm building on the site so
just bear in mind currently if we to
retrofit that building you have twelve
bed spaces on the ground floor so though
people at flood risk the design
distributes that massing to work with
the natural hydrology on site the
building is actually
elevated to the footprint where it meets
the ground is no more than the footprint
of the existing buildings as a void
below it and what we've designed is
assumes of detachable panel so it
protects the perimeter of the building
from people in filling that's one of the
biggest worries from the Environment
Agency equally it's about setting that
as a safe height so that there's not too
many steps but it also allows watering
so there's no tanking it's just a flood
void in an elevated floor and this is
something which the Environment Agency
are keen to do in areas that are prone
to flooding so this will only ever be
called into effect in the Biblical Flood
but it's just a precautionary measure
and it's just an intelligent solution
thank you councillor fielding
the original entrance onto the site was
on the north side of the buildings at
your new heart if you're putting in
there more than you unit you're putting
in there why could you not have come to
the south side with us and therefore
give more space to the property on the
north side I give you a question the key
issue that we have at the moment is
there is a large power cable running
bang the central axis of the site so
therefore in order to minimize
disruption to that essentially the
access route that you can see from the
tramway to the left that is the the flow
of the route through and given that we
are doing a light touch road to allow
the water below it is the solution that
causes the least the least amount of
infrastructure requirements on that site
keeping the old entrance well the
current cable at the moment doesn't go
under the existing building goes along
the flank boundary and this design
reconciles many different qualities so
for example one of the key requirements
when we went out to public consultation
from the members also local councillors
that we were to provide two car parking
spaces per dwelling so going back to the
the government life project on a typical
site you have the footprint requirement
you have space for amenity you have a
requirement for two car parking spaces
so this is a solution that allows a
certain quantum of development and it
meets all the the wider parameters that
a local council set so we in our public
consultation we showed many different
arrangements for this and show that to
the general public at
house and all of those solutions this
with this was deemed to be the
preference thank you so I'm just gonna
go back to the flooding thing and just
in my mind you said it's realistically
it's only ever going to be used in a
biblical flooding event so why is it
absolutely necessary to do this whilst
laudable one and you know it is it
absolutely necessary across the entire
site and it would it not be possible to
have that employed but still have the
houses of the properties lower no
absolutely not
and it's government or its environmental
agency policy what they look at is a one
in 100 year flood event plus 300 mil
tolerance so if they've got their
climate change numbers wrong plus 300
mil freeboard so that is the datum so in
terms of cobble ball liability for a
local authority if you go if you set
your floor levels below the level set by
the Environment Agency and if somebody
dies in that flood then that is passed
back to the local authority so by
default the low of the Environment
Agency's levels that are the ones we
need to work with are those new levels
because clearly the actually caught them
and don't comply with the ashley court
was built before the making space for
water policy came in from Devorah yes is
it is yes can I see a question regards
the second point raised by the previous
speak about the decking of the rear and
that yes you've fitted the panel but
obviously has concerns about that and is
there a reason why you can't drop the
decking down to steps as you suggested
well currently the the school that will
be shown so the distance between that
boundary and the property is that is the
width of a single carriageway so what we
need to remember is currently there's
there's a roadway that exists along that
boundary in terms of that fence or the
screening device that would have the
same controls as you would your boundary
fence so somebody shouldn't be able to
take that down and in terms of the
decking we set up on our physical models
this building is set proud of the
neighbors building so there's there's
Mel over looking into the property and
even if somebody was stood at the
product at the edges of that they do not
look into the garden so we're more than
satisfied that those distances
particular so even if you're looking in
central London there are many many
properties much much closer so this is
this is quite generous and in fairness
we're not in London but thank you for
that counsel Jones I'm not sure that for
me that answer the question because the
question wasn't was your view was the
overlooking accept its is it possible to
bring the decking lower the question for
us is is the level of risk him escape
from the property I think we could it
could be moved it could be dropped lower
the question then is for the safe access
and egress from the people from that
property but it could be tuned to do
that that's correct
so is your concern about safe exit from
the property that someone might not be
able to navigate two steps down look
that what we want to be able to do is is
in the event of a flood that there's a
safe refuge place for people to
congregate that the thing could go down
to I mean there are wider concerns from
the neighbor about over locking and we
clear that from the models because we
can set up and spin the model and that
you can't see from that position
councillor Richard has the build the
existing building ever been flooded do
you have evidence to support that and
the necessity to have it at that higher
and the site neuro the tramway site has
has plugged within the last decade so so
it's two to the west of the west of the
site can you bring a map up and we can
clarify exactly what we're talking about
please yep say ah so it's actually more
am I able to pass this drawing to you I
can preferred if we can actually have
that on the screen placer every yeah
Odyssey but this document so this is is
this public evidence but this I don't if
you can see this but there's a purple we
can circulate this but they stopped yeah
this is in one affirmed wallingford's
report but the whole of the site
including ships and Road and sports
ground behind was inundated fully with
water in 1992 okay I'll have to take
word for that because we don't have that
particularly we can perhaps do that for
two you know again right counts a bass
did you want another question no it's
not two things really the size of the
building that you are producing is how
much greater is it to the building that
we have at the present time and the
other question is I've got a lot of
development that goes on the flood plain
you know that we're not allowed to have
any bigger he's checking how much bigger
is that inside and is it able to you
know like that him for flooding
okay so answering the first question the
footprint of the proposed and the
footprint of the existing are exactly
the same so that's why we're putting
forward the case the roof
exactly the same so then the next
question about the decking within our
design access statement we showed a case
study of a elevated property in Abingdon
called water lane all of that decking is
entirely permeable so it works with the
Environment Agency's best guidance in
terms of flows so you're just in it in
the event of a flood that's not the case
in terms of the way in which the
calculations are undertaken by the
Environment Agency it has no negligible
contribution to the flooding that's why
this is an intelligent solution because
it demonstrates that you can provide
good quality of life to the residents
safely without affecting the floodplain
where there's the garage block is you've
given it a pitch roof is there a reason
why is there a flat in there or is it
why couldn't you put a flat roof similar
to what was there before and also is the
the effect you're having with regards to
the raising the building is it what sort
of effect you're going to have on the
floodplain for the neighboring buildings
if that question is allowed in terms of
the garage the the roof is pitch because
there is a flat proposed above the
garage so that's the purpose of that
design in terms of flooding in this area
there is betterment not just to this
site so in terms of flooding things will
improve as a result of this development
not just on this site but in the area as
well the plan that we were hoping to
show around showed the flooding which is
is in documents that came with the
application so it's on the website in
form part of the application it just
shows you how badly this area flooded in
92 and of course was the flooding again
in 2007 this this scheme will provide
improvement in terms of flooding and
then just just ask answer the second
point to that question so
said how does it potentially reflect
flooding elsewhere so one of the
premises of the live project was not to
push flood risk onto your neighbor so
this again is a good neighbor scenario
in terms of flooding okay thank you Josh
I just wonder if I could see a floor
plan of what's going on is a floor plan
of the garage flat it's just one bedroom
one bedroom and if you have if you
haven't looked on that drawing the the
window position there is in the same
alignment as the window position so it's
a two bedroom it is the same window
alignment as the existing flat e block
okay thank you I think that this
exhorted the questions thank you very
much indeed
I don't counsel audience speaking this
evening nope there Kevin right I will
open up for technical questions members
character defense Thanks we heard about
the decade and floor levels etc can you
enlighten me do you are you in agreement
you think that's appropriate it's fair
do you know when they were installed
brought forward which if you're looking
very confused this so the floor levels
that we have heard about which apart the
deferred code can you enlighten us can
you elaborate on what we've heard can
you verify it or otherwise are we
obliged to stick to that code or is that
just guidance because it's the first
I've heard of it
I mean in terms of the application we
consult
there's two key console T's on this
quite unusual for a site but naturally
been flood zone three we consult
Environment Agency and the lead local
flood authority for Warwickshire both of
those I've come to a point where they
can raise no objection subject to can do
so they've accepted that the levels as
part of this are acceptable and they
they won't exacerbate understand I mean
they're very clear they would do that
because they've been raised but if they
weren't raised do you think we would be
getting an objection or not given I know
the area reasonably well I know it's
further down the road we've granted in
that certain in the last ten years we've
granted developments without the need to
raise would we have still gotten a
support or would have been I'm not able
to answer that because it's not the
scheme that's before us that those
agencies of Assessors came before us and
it may or may not be acceptable to the
myth that the actual levels would drop
so I speculate whether that would work
or not I just wonder if we could refresh
my memory on what whether we have any
guidance about loss of daylight there
any particular guidance because I've
said there's guidance about separation
distances and windows but a particular
concern here is about the level of
sunlight which will be blocked in the
garden as a result of the height of that
building the key way that we test some
daylight runs sunlight sorry daylight is
measured by the 45 degree test which in
this case you would measure from the
windows at the rear of the neighbor and
you'd measure it in that direction there
so clearly this this building actually
falls within that area there so on that
counts it fails it but of course you've
then got to look at the distance because
if you go far enough down that 45-degree
line you'll come across building so
whilst it doesn't meet it in that regard
the significant distance which is 21
metres mitigates any harm to the
daylight to that property and makes it
comparable to the existing situation but
the issue isn't just the issue of
daylight into the property it's about
the daylight in the immunity of the
garden is there any guidance about
because obviously if you measure the 45
degree rule looking which it contravenes
anyway I understand what you say about
mitigating about distance but we're not
just talking about the effect of
daylight into the property no of course
yeah if you then obviously you're bound
to look at not just property also the
garden and a factor 2 way into account
is the fact it's a relatively large
garden if it was a smaller garden that
was that perhaps the point to make is if
the garden was just this area here in
that building was there that might not
be acceptable but it's important to take
into account how much amenity space is
available for that property and also to
take into account the fact that it's
coming closer it's coming closer at a
point further away from the existing
building where that overshadows it but
yes it's a factor taking to account
particular whose guard sunlight being to
the south of it it will cast a shadow
will based at a different point from the
existing just just to finish off in
answer your question there's no guidance
that we have no no policy that we have
hard and fast on sunlight Casa fielding
when you're doing the initial
discussions with regards to any anything
raised about moving keeping the existing
entrance and keeping the building line
back onto the southern boundary and
therefore give more protection to the
the house because I can't see any
problems with the garage is being moved
further south I'm afraid to say I
appreciate the argument blue portion we
have to stick to the scheme in front of
us we cannot redesign it obviously at
this point so appreciating the the
reasoning of the logic behind it that
some portion we have to stick with the
scheme in front of us I'll then no other
questions
okay thank you they're not opening up
for debate counsel fielding first in
caso bonds counselor Kosovo sort of
quite happy with it really had changing
the street scene and making it look
better is roughly that's what the ward
member said when she went to bridge but
I'm not so sure I'm a bit concerned
about the effect on the neighbor ideally
I would have liked a site visit but it's
a bit late in the day really but I'm
noticing the now I've gone into it in
depth I'm not happy at all Thank You
chair I'm not I recognize this this site
needs to change it's a pretty miserable
building so I'm I've got no problem the
principle of developing this site what
I'm uncomfortable about is this this
what's been alluded to is tanking this
void whatever it is the flood stuff I I
just don't feel that it's I'm not
entirely convinced it's necessary and
without supporting evidence from the
environmental agencies that we've
consulted I can only take their word
from the applicant as to its knees which
I'm uncomfortable doing so I mean I
don't know almost feel like I want to
move to defer so that we can get that
information so I can understand what
that impact is get a bit more
information about the flooding here
before making a decision because I'm not
comfortable making it a decision to
build a decision to grant without that
knowledge and I don't know if anyone
else would support that or not Kathy
Jones for different reasons on I'm
thinking along roughly symbolize in the
sense that I like many elements of the
scheme is cleaving a lot of hard work
done to make it right it's definitely a
betterment of the site there's clearly
been a lot of thought given to the
flooding element of it and it's
impressive but I think I'm almost a
little bit worried that in the you know
the keenness to address all of those
major China
the site they've overlooked some of them
the more simplest of things which is the
impact on neighbor it's apparent that it
is possible to reduce that decking which
was such a simple thing to do and it
would obviously meet and and deal with
one of the concerns of the neighbor and
I am concerned with the garage space I
mean I actually hear what counts of
fielding says about you know is it not
possible for that to be some adjustment
so that that block is if it's got to be
that height and that's a question does
it have to be that high because I am
concerned I for me I'm uncomfortable I
do take on board the point that that
garden it is of a certain size but there
the reality is that house and that
garden was there first and and they the
occupants of it have a right to be able
to enjoy that space and it would appear
that already there's an issue with light
and I can see the real issue all of a
sudden you have a there's no point
having a stripper sun light at the
bottom of your garden if the the amenity
space at the top is is in complete
darkness so it's a it's a really
important thing you know people buy
houses because of the light you know
that can be a deciding factor as to why
some on a purchase a house so it can
have a major impact on someone so I'm
not I'm not comfortable with the fact
that we've got a building that's closer
yes further away but closer higher and I
think it will have an unacceptable
impact and so I want to know but I don't
want to reject this application outright
I want to know something can be done to
mitigate that which is either adjusting
you know how close that building is to
the boundary you know something along
those lines I don't feel convinced that
it has to or does it have to be that
high so I don't want to you know say
absolutely no to this but I want to know
if the applicant is able to adjust some
of those things counter carries would
you like to
I'm sorry concerned about that the
decking aspect it seems to me that you
could reduce the decking down to ground
level or remove it entirely that's not
an essential part of the building I'm
quite happy with the building being
raised and all the exclamation I think
it's fantastic actually that we've got
this innovation coming into Stratford
and leading the way for other
development but the decking and the
overlooking of the garden we had a
similar thing overlooking a neighbor's
garden my neighbor's garden in fact at
this committee and I was surprised that
when it went to appeal the it was it was
held up that in that location you know
with such a large garden you would
expect an element of privacy which you
wouldn't expect in London for instance
and from that decking from the nearest
decking to 61a I think it is if you're
sitting you're gonna be sitting out
there you're not just walking down steps
you're spending your summer afternoons
out there gazing I think you would be
gazing or could certainly be gazing
towards your neighbor's garden I know
there's a 1.7 meter fence thing which
may or may not remain there but from
other points on that decking you would
see down into the garden you wouldn't
see to the house fair enough we would
see to this to the garden which is their
amenity space so I'm concerned that they
could given time just drop that and
everybody will be happy okay I'm just
picking up a few things now I think the
general consensus is it's a good idea to
have this scheme in principle there are
issues with it however as a pointed out
now by the the the neighbor as well what
I'm going to do is to pause proceedings
for a few minutes now I'd like ppreciate
if I can have a chat to the agent and
the architect for five minutes if you
wouldn't mind and there are a few little
things I can just discuss with you if
that's all right with you so I'm going
to pause a meeting for 5-10 minutes okay
thank you everybody I've been advised
that we aren't allowed to debate or
discuss this item in any detail outside
of this chamber and for that I apologize
to everybody however members before you
are the options obviously if we want to
we can defer this item for clarification
of the three main items before us those
are one is the flooding mitigation
measures which council richest ism was
asked about the second is the garage and
the plot above it and the shadowing
effect on that and the third is the
decking and the potential overlooking
element is I correct me if I'm wrong but
I think those are the three items that
are of concern to this committee I would
certainly be happy to I think it was the
riches his proposal to defer I mean it
might not be for exactly the same reason
but the thing the thing that I would
like to be addressed is whether the
applicant can bring down the height of
the garage to mitigate any loss of
sunlight in the garden and whether that
decking can be reduced to address any
issues that neighbor has at 61a about
overlooking and then there obviously
other issues so yes they are my two
particular concerns and without that I
don't feel I can say yes to this
application or grant it at this stage
okay I was quite happy now I'm not happy
and I think the permit is the only way
forward right yeah just just for members
to know whether deferral there's always
a chance if the determination period has
expired that the applicant could appeal
for non determination so just something
to bear in mind we don't want to stop
there going through we just want to get
it right miss fielding I'm in favor of
the scheme because I think it
there is needs to be done up I just
think with a bit of thought more room
could be made against the neighbor in on
the north side and I go back to what I
mean
arguing and therefore to great extent I
agree with what the others are saying
that we defer it until we give it print
a revised scheme or more information
thank you right in that case then cancel
thank you for the pennant benefit for
the public's benefit I want to make it
absolutely clear that nothing was
debated and discussed in the room back
there we were sat and our solicitors
come in and explain to us exactly what
situation is and that was it was cool to
help so I just want to make that
absolutely clear my proposal is to defer
I on the basis of a lack of information
around these Defra codes we do not have
the right as far as I'm aware and
correct me if I'm wrong planners and
solicitor we didn't have the right to
defer for an applicant to make changes
to their application this is purely
deferral on the basis of more
information required on these Defra
codes if the application if the
applicants decide to make adjustments
they're entitled to do that but I want
to make absolutely clear that this is a
proposal to defer for more information
fair enough on that particular point
then and I have a proposal do I have a
seconder counselor jars there for
members the vote before is to defer this
item for for more information to be
presented by the air at the agents all
those in favor
unanimous Channel thank you this
committee therefore resolved to defer
this item is 17/1 87 5/4 thank you
the next item on the agenda is 17 / 103
6/4 163 Locksley Road Stratton 11 and
the presenting officer is again Eddie
wrench
Thank You chair the application site is
located when the built-up area boundary
of stratford-upon-avon as shown here
over the red dot black dot in the center
of the slide the site is directly to the
south of Stratford Golf Club in his
access off the Loxley Road to the south
this is an aerial photo which shows the
application site and surrounding built
form this photo is from the existing
front elevation of the property and this
is to the rear these are the proposed
front and rear elevation of 3d
visualizations of how the proposed
property would look again these are the
side elevations of the proposed property
these four photos show the application
site in relation to 161 lockable roads
to the west of the site these four
photos show the application start in
relation to a hundred and sixty five
lakh zero to the east
finally this slide shows the proposed
replacement dwelling in the context of
the 45-degree line test from the
principal front and rear hubs for
Windows of the neighboring properties
chairman there are no up two updates to
report and the recommendation is to grab
Commission subjects of the nine
conditions and four notes on page 56 of
the agenda thank you thank you
our first speaker is Nicole Vasquez
thank you
in your own time you have three minutes
when you're ready press the button at
the bottom of the year microphone in
turn yelling that's it fine in your own
time
it's very complicated but thank you we
got the pictures ready okay that's good
thank you
as neighbors we're concerned that this
house is significantly larger than the
dormer bungalow it replaces it's in fact
almost 1/3 larger in its footprint and
more than double the size of the
existing bungalow the photo shows the
existing bungalow taken from the rear
garden of 161 if you can visualize the
proposed house it will sit further back
than the corner of one sticks one that
you see on the right-hand side of the
photograph and a double height only 90
centimeters from the boundary fence it
will be overbearing crate overshadowing
a significant loss of light and privacy
with oversized windows to the rear of
the proposed house
Nexo toe similarly if you look at the
photo taken from 165 with 161 in the
background you have to again visualize
reposed house which actually ends to the
right of that photograph right on the
very right edge of the photograph you'll
see that there be the same problem with
regards to loss of light overbearing
overshadowing
and loss of privacy next photo this
photo shows the windows in the family
room of 161 which were installed to
obtain light in a northern facing room
they would no longer see sky next photo
or indeed greenery and would look
directly onto a two-story brick wall 90
centimeters from that from the fence 165
also have windows that looked directly
towards proposed house which will lose
vital light in the afternoon and look at
a two-story wall 40 centimeters from the
boundary fence we understand that the
Stratford planning and have taken note
of the extension to your house guidance
and in this side windows have little
automatic protection however the same
guidance states that each case will be
judged on individual circumstances which
we are asking you to do the guidance
continues to say that care should be
taken to protect the overlooking
overshadowing and overbearing
particularly rating to the area
immediately outside the rear of the
house which is often used for sitting
out the proposed house would create
problems loss of light and privacy issue
not only within the living areas of the
adjacent properties but in the area
immediately on to the patios the front
of the proposed house next slide what is
it outside the existing footprint closer
to the fence and further forward in the
bay window you can see here further
forward than the natural building line
the councillors made a good national
rational and fair policy in cs20 and
this should be upheld we believe that it
would be fundamentally a mistake to
allow the replacement of a modest dolna
bungalow with a large two-story house of
more than double this size we need to
protect important homes suitable for
elderly and people with disabilities we
understand sorry we understand the
desire the developer to build as large
as possible to maximize profit however
we would ask you to when granting
permission if it is for a two-story
house that we would request the
developer be limited to building within
the existing footprint of the building
and any increase to high to the rear
does not have a detrimental impact on
either light or privacy for the
neighbors there is a loss of trees yes
all the planting that is between the two
houses at 161 and 162 go to make room
for the building because it is coming
nearer to the house they won't get a
picture yeah thank you
any other questions okay thank you very
much you just press the button at the
bottom and appreciate it thank you
right our next speaker is Rachel best
from stance Kate
in your entire region that's alright
right thank you
your offices reporter set out an
assessment against the planning policy
with which I concur and the principle of
development is supported the site is
within the built-up area boundary and
its context as a built-up street scene
of houses and bungalows of similar size
and design to this proposal the bungalow
to be replaced is in poor repair and the
proposed analysis whilst larger makes
more efficient use of the sizeable plot
it sits comfortably within the built
form and character of the street and is
a entirely appropriate in its context
two sets of amendments have been made
which aim to address the concerns of
neighbors and councillor mrs. Ralph
these have led to the proposed house
being cut back in size to keep it within
the building line of the neighboring
houses and an overall reduction in the
size the footprint print of the proposal
is only 20 centimetres wider than the
existing bungalow footprint albeit two
storeys and the roof has a Hipps gable
to keep the house down height down as
far as possible adjacent to the boundary
the footprint depth of the proposal is 3
metres greater than the existing
although it should be remembered that
the original dwelling could be extended
under permitted development prior
approval rights by up to 8 metres in
depth that single-story
or 3 meters at to storing knowledge in
those concerns are met the final
comments from councillor Alf expressed
concern that two storey development will
affect the light at the back for both
neighbors this is the North facing
elevation to consider this at your
officer has assessed the proposal
against the council's guidelines in
extending your home including plotting
the 25 and 45 degree lines and confirms
that guidelines are met and indeed
exceeded the ground-floor side kitchen
window at number one six one is a
secondary window to the room and it's
set below the height of the height of
the fence
so the proposal should not result in an
adverse impact to orang2 refusal of
permission in terms of assurances that
side windows on the proposal are obscure
glazed your offices that's now to
condition to be imposed on a permission
all other matters such as ecology and
highways are satisfied the Town Council
have no comments overall the proposal
makes efficient use of land within the
built-up area boundary it sits
comfortably in its context in the street
scene of comparable houses it respects
neighbor amenity and it's sustainable
development to which we respectfully
request permission should be granted in
accordance with your officers
recommendation thank you second
definition they have okay thank you I'm
trying to stop you early and amendments
were made to try and address the
concerns and that resulted in the
overall size of the dwelling being
significantly reduced and they rented
the dwelling being cut back so that it
comes within the building line of the
neighboring properties yes they
concerned you said significantly reduce
in from the previous iterations how much
is significant please well if you're
looking for an actual LAN floor space
certainly cut back at the front by well
cut back at the front to bring it back
within the building line so it was
certainly a half a metre moved cut back
half a metre at least at the front which
resulted in a redesign internally
because it resulted in a reduced with
garage and a smaller utility room
because the whole house had to be
reduced in size it was also reduced at
the first floor level so
they main bedroom is reduced in size as
well that's a significant I consider
significant yes
cancel witches thank you
the 3d rendered drawings they do they
accurately reflect the materials you're
planning to use they are the materials
that are intended to be used as a
referred to on the drawings but there is
also a condition and the mission
requiring samples of materials to be
submitted so that can be reserved for
approval cash bonds
did you just checking you've taken a bit
off the front but you have another did
to the back no no Castle tilting the
ridge heights of the new heart building
what is it like in relation to them two
on either side although the ones on
either side are they roughly the same
height there is a street scene that was
submitted I believe and a topographic
survey has been done to pick up the
heights of the existing buildings I
think it results in they proposed
dwelling being about four hundred
centimeters higher than number one six
one and about a meter higher than number
one six five thank you
I know the questions Ridge in the center
at the building because it's got hit the
side
yep you've got a rich height there then
you've got a line above is that the the
because of the rich height that shows
there looks like it's blow than the two
on either side is there or is there a
different height there different of the
building that on that flooring the
dotted line reflects the roof of the
proposal right okay thank you thank you
very much thank you
our next speaker is counselor Roth
we have a policy cs20 which states that
the replacement dwelling will be well
sited in relation to the existing site
and buildings not visually intrusive if
not significantly larger than the
dwelling it replaces I have an email
here from Richard Bergman stating that
it is significantly larger but more
importantly it is significantly deeper
we believe that the proposed house will
sit forward of the building line along
this path the Loxley vote we believe
there is an error in the site plan used
in flavor of the proposal to express the
nominal building line as it does not
match the satellite Google image or the
actual view from the street the size of
the proposed dwelling is just over twice
the size of the original dwelling
because if its size this large proposed
building sits in a relatively small plot
and is built up to both boundaries this
proposed dwelling is also deeper than
the existing building which will cause
problems which you have explained about
later on
by building this property so tightly in
the plot there will be no light through
either side of the property looking out
onto vegetation in back gardens there
are examples of the large houses
recently built further up the Loxley
Road but you will note that there is a
space around them to see through the
sides to the vegetation as they are not
built right up to the boundaries of the
neighboring properties this proposal
does alter the aspect along the rocky
road because of the lack of space
between properties it would almost
caused a terracing effect the boundary
to the side of 165 is extreme extremely
close to the house the current dormer
bungalow does not intrude on 165 as the
single-story garage separates the two
but because this current proposed was
two-story and built to the existing
boundary it will I believe have a
detrimental effect on the residents
living in 165 because of its close
proximity and over Berenice the
residence in number 161 Locksley Road
had two long windows put in the side of
their family room at the back in order
to gain maximum benefit from the Sun as
the French windows of their property are
facing north by building a two-story
house with an extension at the back only
two metres away means that all light
will be obliterated from these two long
windows they will effectively be
being out on to a brick wall being
inside of the proposed house and have no
light coming through at all interesting
in your previous application about
lighting to a garden this new property
will have a large first-floor window
overlooking next doors patio and the
other side which will currently have an
impact on their amenities it's a shame
that the developers did not have
discussions with the neighbors and
myself as I truly believe there's a
compromise to be had
I guess because they were not be living
in it they thought it unnecessary if
they slightly narrowed the property and
did not build so far out at the back
then the neighbors would be happy as
their light would not be compromised I I
reiterate policy cs20 if we keep
allowing in replacement houses to be
built significantly larger on existing
small plots then we're I'm we are in
serious danger of changing whole
landscapes and discrete streetscapes for
the future I ask that you refuse this
planning application and suggest that
developers further discussions with us
to reach an acceptable compromise thank
you Thank You councillor just to pick up
you mentioned about being built to both
boundaries but there is a gap down there
and I think the agent said it was only
20 centimeters wider than the current
it's still a very very narrow boundary
and because of the because of the -
because you're losing trees and things
and because it's a two-story you just
create you just can't you won't be able
to see through because they'll be
fencing it's it's inevitable if you look
further up the Loxley Road you'll see
much larger houses but they're built
smaller on the plot so you can see the
vegetation behind okay thank you there
any other questions you'd like to ask
councillor off yes yep you just can you
clarify what you were talking about the
patio and amenities - right well you
mentioned in your previous application
about the amenities of next-door
neighbors and their right to be able to
sit in their patio without being
overlooked currently they're not
overlooked either site they're not
overlooked possess a bungalow
because there is a very large rear
window at the back of this new
development and because it's further
back it will look home for both patios
they will not be able to sit in their
patio in the nude if they wish without
being overlooked that the house needs to
be less deep so that there will be no
overlooking to their amenities in the
garden thank you take your residence
Christmas tree line - I might join her
you never know let's not go there thank
you very much any other pertinent
questions please for Council Rock no
thank you very much Council thank you
right technical questions casters first
yeah thanks
you just clarify for me the heights
height differences I know we did ask
this of the Asian she said 400
centimeters which to me is 4 meters that
seems excessive judging from that it's
40 centimeters perhaps but if you could
clarify the difference in Heights 4 1 6
1 165 and 163 I think 400 millimeters so
yeah 4 centimeters
so do you mean the difference between
the proposed and the two adjacent Ridge
Heights yes 37 centimeters taller than
161 and about a meter taller than 165
you're very happy first one not so much
for the second but that's fine thing 99
I think I was actually interested you
know in terms of the pallet of materials
because you've got this gray and white
render and I just wondered if there were
any other examples on cuz I hadn't seen
not sure I've seen that much on Locksley
Road of that and it does strike me some
English sticks out a bit okay we just go
back to the view which is a superimposed
3d yeah and looking at that bottom one
which is superimposing the proposed
dwelling that actually looks lower than
the building to the left where as we
know it's within a centimeter or two so
it's not the scale is it no I mean it is
a freely visualized agent so it's not a
hundred percent accurate as a scaled
elevation it's purely for a general idea
certainly wouldn't take heights or
anything
Yeah right counsel Rolf mentioned about
sight lines through between the
buildings what have you got to say on
that particular point please as you can
see from that for what it's worth as a
3d visualisation there would be
significantly narrowed over and above
the existing so yeah it wouldn't be as
had the same open field it does
currently but in offices view it doesn't
take that to such an extent that it's
harmful enough to refuse permission
right there taking it the other point
about overlooking on the patio we won't
go into any more details on that point
but have we'll all the aspects that
you've considered on that place
[Music]
I assume it's overlooking from one of
the first-floor windows around here is
that right no chance robbers got this
bit I don't know if we can see from the
3d you so I mean the exist the proposed
house is gonna bring the back of the
house back further here so I mean terms
of 45 it is going to be it's a linear
form of development so overlooking
you're probably talking more about the
end of their garden than directly out to
the rear of their house generally we're
looking at overlooking it is towards
primary mean tea space directly out to
the back
can I just have two questions there are
no side windows on the proposed during
there are some there are some superb
site proposed windows but they are
proposed to be obscure glazed sorry um
do apologize will not have to go further
than their members casa fielding can you
show the two floor plans ground and so
where where is that the the window
that's causing the consternation is the
on the left-hand is that that's the
proposed that's the proposed here so
that it's that window there that's where
as the one on the ground floor is if
patio doors are gathered
Thank You councillor Carrington Council
bonds hmm I'm gonna ask a question about
cs20 and the significantly large a bit
which seems the blaringly obvious thing
to me it we don't hit but before that
can I see a plan of the footprint
compared to the neighbors please can I
see a footprint compared to the
neighbors with them with that something
like that how far it comes out at the
back okay we keep that one up a bit and
could you give me sir I'm struggling
I read cs20 and I read ahead in our
report and that's relevant to this one
but CS 20 is coming up next
maybe and the argument is black and
white
nice and simple significantly larger or
something worse to that effect this is
blatant obviously significantly larger
so what why are we not using that in the
officers report it goes to look at
policy CS 20 and looked at exactly that
point is it significantly larger and
concludes it yes it is significantly
largest as it's self-evident that the
replacement of a bungalow with the
two-story detached dwelling will be
significantly larger but then
importantly under cs20 it requires you
to then go and look at other
considerations and in this case the
other considerations are to look at the
street scene and to look at the
character of other dwellings along there
and importantly the necessity to find
some level of harm resulting from that
so the point I'm making is it can be
significantly larger but that's only
unacceptable if you then go on to find
harm resulting from that
like isness fine thank you can I just
practice seeing the reticular slide I
noticed that there are a number of
properties on there which have no one
side for example is a gate boundary one
two three four
is that correct I'm only reading that
correctly in other words one side of the
property is against the boundaries as
this one shows access other side is that
correct I believe the proposed would
have some side access I think is around
a meter to one of the sides but yeah
going from this plan
I think it's 167 looks like it's built
up to the boundary to the east one two
one five nine is Bill up to the side as
well but deserve a side access so you
know lot of the houses are quite similar
plot widths and they do build quite
close to the boundaries okay thank you
quatre fielding in the castle bar I
think castle bars was first I do politic
as appealing but but yourself was just
checking this window that he's concerned
he's not a balcony it's just a windows
it it's just a window he's doing there
yet talking about decking and sunbathing
as the the gardens are on the north side
of the houses you know the Sun will be
sometime before or it gets to the
gardens so I don't know why the decking
is so important with at the back of the
the houses do you have a question please
we're gonna do debate in a moment
counselor someone just mentioned decking
is everything we can see there in that
outline built form we're not talking
about decking we're talking about like
two stories right yes that's effectively
a block plan so all you see there is
built form if there's decking or patios
that's not shown
okay any other questions for ID
otherwise I'll go to debate council
courage I think too big I think cs20
clearly says include I can't remember
the exact working that if it's
significantly larger that's against
policy we've had guidance from our
planning officer on that and I'm glad
about that because that'll come in
useful and it comes in useful here if
there is harm that I think there is harm
the way it's built out at the back it it
protrudes well beyond the left-hand
neighbor and that you know that that
will be overbearing on their on their a
media garden space outside their house
on the left there that's I just think
that's it's too big too far back and
won't have a negative effect on that
neighbor especially but also some more
on one six five and I think therefore it
is significantly larger and because of
that it does cause harm
I'd recommend we reviews Casa balance
did you what I was I was in my belize
there's not all a bungalow down and made
him into risers there isn't any
bungalows left and luckily road is
exactly the same it was all bungalows
and i think there's only about three
left this is what's happened before that
i have concern over that window but
isn't really a plane region Borobudur
thank you
whilst i greater shame to lose a
bungalow i do disagree with counselor
carriage if we take 165 as an example
and if you can go back to the overview
with the red line we can see from that
that 165 is a relative new build it's
very different from what's built there
clearly that one new 165 is demonstrably
larger than what it was shown on that
previous slide this is seeking to do
almost exactly the same thing I don't
think it's
against our our cs20 policy at all the
only issue I do have is over the use of
materials that I do think the design
there is pretty ugly I'd like to think
that if we do opt for grant that we can
condition the materials to be similar to
one six one one six five so it's
actually in keeping with that street
scene and on that basis I would actually
propose that we go off as a
recommendation and grant with that
condition I think I'll just clarify with
cancer cures you did say that you say
you're if you recommended a proposal are
you happy to do it because you did get
in first do you want to propose that
that's right yes I would yeah okay well
we look for a second in a moment now
there any other and because of Jones
because I do I can see that just because
it's significantly larger because if
you're going to lots of people have
replaced their smaller houses on this
road with something bigger and so it's
always going to be something bigger and
that's fair enough
just for me I just feel like I couldn't
have just been a tiny bit smaller a tiny
bit less deep if it was just marginally
address those things it would just feel
like it just fit in a bit more
comfortably because on that I appreciate
that that's not sort of a scale sort of
visual but it just does feel like it's
all a bit cramped and just losing all of
the I mean but on the other hand I sort
of think well just because they happen
to be last to come to the party why
should they be penalized because clearly
people on the other side of almost built
up and sort of taken that space in
advance in a way if you're not I mean
are and I'm not a big fan of the
material I mean I don't know if it's
something that can be addressed in
condition hugely in terms of the whole
look of it but I just don't know I'm
sitting on the fence at the moment
didn't like you at all
I think from my perspective I think the
tapasya there has been a huge amount of
building back back to next door both
sides so I agree with what you're saying
that the last one to the party shouldn't
be penalized necessarily for that I do
agree with also that he goes too far
that the back I feel that it's just
exactly the back a bit but is that a
reason for refusal and I think that's a
judgment call that we have to make on
this particular point the other aspect
about building up to the boundaries well
it obviously doesn't but I noticed a
number of properties do along that road
so we've we've obviously at some point
Kranti plan commission to let that so
again I don't I don't necessarily put
that into the argument for refusal this
is a tricky one okay so he casts a
carriage did you want to ask about a
completely both sigh you know they were
presumably bungalows either side of this
bungalow at one point and their great
big hair is is now said there is a
question of fairness and that's not what
I'm thinking of you know that's not what
I'm thinking of I don't think as a big
house from the front we can argue
against it on that road or in this
situation especially I think what
they've done with the hip moves is
actually quite good and it reduces the
the massing effect so I don't think we
can argue with what it looks like at the
front mark my only beef with this is how
it affects the neighbors amenity at the
back so again I'd propose we reject well
I would just draw consular carriages
eyes to the slide we have on the screen
now that demonstrates the 45 degree
lines and how it doesn't impact
significantly I suggested if if I may
I'm not talking about sort of sidelines
from windows I'm talking about this is a
two-story building at that point going
out behind somebody else's building
which doesn't at the moment I mean
that's unusual to have a building go
behind the building line at the back to
two stories that close to somebody's you
know a media amenity space that's that's
what I'm saying I'm not talking about
the 45 degree line anyway that's not
getting up to six if you want to go into
debate this lets do cancer fielding
finish of the building it doesn't it
doesn't look right they're both red
brick either side and also I agree with
what could be pulled a bit forward it's
more in line with the front of 165 right
in the middle on everything here council
Gonski well I was led to believe that
they'd actually pushed it back a bit
because that's what the board member
wanted so I appreciate looking at that
looks to me as Eric it could have gone
back this meter that they pulled it back
or took the front of so you can't have
it always it is a a road of changing
styles and we've got to just look at
what we've got I don't think there's any
real reasonably fusion that would would
would hold up except that back when
right well I do have an a proposal for
refusal don't have a seconder for that
council Jones members the vote before
you is to refuse planning permission for
1700 103 such 6/4 all those in favor
three chairman all those against four
chairman that motion fails
so Drive a proposal for the council
Richards you're proposing for my I did
propose that we grant in failure in
favor in line with the officer
recommendation with the additional
condition of the materials thank you I
took into council fielding right members
the vote before you is to grant a plan
permission to 17-0 103 6/4 all those in
favor fortune against three chairman
this committee therefore resolves to
grant plan permission for 1701 oh three
6/4 thank you
just clarify how we deal with the
materials the way I proposed to do that
is to keep the condition we've got and
to have a note on saying it is expected
that when those details come in they
should follow the character set by the
properties either side yes I agree and
that we've brought back - yes and so
happy with that I'll bring it back to
myself and confirm that thank you right
the next item on the agenda is 17/2 five
nine nine slash Falls Robin Hood farm
Dancy lair Green Lane and it is Alison
who's presenting
thank you
Thank You chairman and the site is
located in the open countryside between
Thanh within' art into the northwest and
dandy green railway station to the
southeast it's also within the art and
special landscape area and the West
Midlands Greenbelt the position of the
site was denoted by the black dot the
application site is urged in red on this
plan the site is accessed from dandy
Green Lane and there are several
residential properties to the south of
the Lane there's a public right-of-way
to the east of the site this is an
aerial view of the site showing the
existing agricultural buildings on the
site as well as the existing farmhouse
so there's the existing farmhouse these
are the buildings which proposed for
conversion and other buildings are
proposed for removal this is the
existing site plan the plan is colored
with the applicant claim the area
colored green is the current domestic
area that the yellow area is the current
access which has a shared agricultural
and domestic use and the blue marks the
proposed extended domestic area the
white areas to the east of the site
denote the parts of the site that are to
be retained in agricultural use this is
the proposed site plan with the same
color coding this plan shows the extent
of the build of the buildings proposed
for attention
the next two slides show the proposed
elevations of the dwelling and
outbuildings to be converted to the
right-hand side of this first slide
visual representations oh no sorry
oh yeah I'm sorry and to the right hand
side of this first side are the post
garage to be retained sorry the next two
slides show the proposed elevation to
the dwelling and the out bernie's to be
converted to the right-hand side of this
first slide are visual representations
of the proposed dwelling the north and
south elevations at the top of this
slide show the context of the proposed
dwelling alongside the more traditional
agricultural buildings which would be
retained and converted and the modern
agricultural buildings proposed for
retention in agricultural use so the
ones to be retained are these ones here
and the unconverted and the wants to be
retained in agricultural use of these
buildings here this slide shows the
existing floor plans the floor plans
colored yellow denote the existing
dwelling and the floor panels colored
purple denote the existing agricultural
buildings this slide shows the floor
plan to the proposed wearing the ground
floor wing shown in the center of the
slide is the converted agricultural
buildings and the wing to the left is a
new build two-story structure which runs
through from the front to the rear of
the proposed dwelling this photo shows
the front elevation of the farmhouse on
the left the hard standing to the front
and some of the existing agricultural
buildings on the right this photo shows
the site access Drive and some of the
agricultural buildings in the background
this photo shows the rear if the
farmhouse with the existing agricultural
buildings in the background and that's
another view of the rear of the
farmhouse chairman there are no updates
to report and the recommendation is to
refuse the application for the reason
set out on page 71 of the agenda thank
you very much indeed I don't believe
we've been on a site visit but it did
come it did come to us some months ago
in April yeah you may have a
recollection of it from that particular
meter yes yes there was a site visit as
part of the meeting back in April so
that's probably the one you were called
thank you our first speakers accounts
for the Carol Shepperd
Thank You councillor you have three
minutes in your own time good evening
and since joining time with Irish
Council approximately two years ago this
is the only application I can recall
where the Parish Council has actually
decided to support the applicant having
been involved in the NDP process I have
a specific interest in a historic and
natural environment of the parish and
some of the committee members may recall
that I recently attended a meeting to
object to a proposed development on the
fringe of the conservation area
following a historic England sponsored
workshop I have surveyed with others the
LSS fees within the parish and some of
the smaller settlements including Danza
green I'm familiar with this site which
lies in the odds and special landscape
area the farmhouse here is not listed
and sadly is in a poor state of repair
indeed the officer includes the comment
that it is not suitable for renovation
in her report surely the next best
option is for new farmhouse in work sure
courtyard style using vernacular
materials to be constructed in its place
the Parish Council has judged that the
proposal is sympathetic to its location
and surroundings
the design proposed to retain youths lie
to the best of the buildings on the site
including the threshing barn and hovel
in the sense of an open shelter which is
the oldest structure on the site
meanwhile so are the least visually
appealing structures as well as some of
the existing hard standing will be
removed so that the openness of the
green belts will actually be improved
the improvement is obvious when you view
and compare the existing layout with a
proposed I will leave detailed
discussions of the increase in both
floor space and volume which may
ultimately determine the outcome of this
application to the officer and the
applicants planning consultant turning
to the natural environment although some
of the low quality low amenity trees and
a small amount of hedging are to be
removed there are no plans to remove any
of the mature Oaks and most of the
boundary hedging which are
characteristics of the art and landscape
the committee might consider protecting
the miniature access and condition of
the planning should they decide to
approve the application local residents
are in favor of this game and no
objections have been recorded to date
indeed neighbors were to welcome the
tidying up of the slides which will
prevent any further occupation by
squatters and vandalism mr. weh has
listened to the feedback on his previous
application and is now submitting a plan
for an albeit substantial family home
which is attractively designed to sit
comfortably in its plot and with
therefore enhance the local environment
and street view 30 seconds please my
accounts fine
thus the parish council is happy to
support his application thank you thank
you very much
mmm right obviously you've come to this
insignificant detail and I hear what you
have been saying as regards your your
knowledge of this particular area so how
do you um
say that what do you say against the
fact that the officers put down that
harm is caused and there are no very
special circumstances to allow this
development how do you address them I
think I think I mentioned that actually
it will enhance the green belts because
some of the building is going to be
removed and therefore there will be
greater openness in on the site are
there any other questions of our
counselor okay thank you very much right
our next speaker is Jane Cashner
welcome back Jane
right Jane you have three minutes when
you're in time just before I start could
I have the slides which I sent in that's
okay and just as an introduction for
visceral way the applicant is here to
answer any questions
good evening you may remember a previous
application at this site which was
refused at committee in April whilst I
was not involved in that application the
applicants and I have watched the
webcast carefully considered your
comments and gone back to the drawing
board as you can see from photos 1 & 2
Robin Hood farm is in need of
redevelopment the applicant is seeking
to create his family home here we've
taken on board your previous comments
relating to design photo 3 shows the
barns we are retaining with historic
interest slide 4 shows we propose an
attractive workshare farmhouse design
with courtyard the key areas of
objection the Planning Office has raised
of the Greenbelt
and scale of the replacement dwelling
we're under no illusion that the scale
of the new house is larger than the
existing but we feel that there are
material considerations our very special
circumstances which justify the size in
terms of Greenbelt
paragraph 79 of the MPP F states that
the fundamental aim of Greenbelt policy
is to prevent urban sprawl by keeping
land permanently open if you toggle
between the existing and proposed slides
five and six it's clear to me that this
proposal improves openness plus it
returns over 1200 square meters of land
covered by agricultural buildings back
to being permanently open the office the
report suggests little weight should be
given to this because agricultural
buildings are appropriate forms of
development in the Greenbelt however it
can't be disputed that green belt land
which has an absence of any built form
as is part of our proposal contributes
far more to keeping land permanently
open the aim of Greenbelt policy it's
also noted that the planning officer has
said that the visual benefit can be
considered to be significant
there are many figures which have been
quoted in the report and I would draw
your attention to the fact that the
proposal would result in a 44 percent
reduction in footprint and 29 percent
reduction in volume across the site this
is unique to this site this along with
the other very special circumstances set
out at the bottom of page 66 of your
agenda outweigh the harm these reasons
also justify the scale of the proposed
dwelling the offices have quoted a
volume increase of two hundred and fifty
two percent but this sets aside the fact
that the bonds to be retained could be
converted to ancillary accommodation in
that instance our slope as shown on
slide seven the dwelling would only be
fifty three percent increase in volume
not two hundred and fifty two percent
and only a twenty eight percent increase
in floor space turning to local opinion
during five seconds the parish council
and councillor Atkinson support the
proposal there are six letters of
support from locals and no objections
and Consort ease we have listened to
your previous objections substantially
altered the previous scheme engaged with
locals and demonstrated very special
circumstances to support the application
thank you for listening thank you very
much right I think first of all can you
go back to slide six please
the on the right-hand side there are
cutting if I'm wrong those are the
buildings the agricultural buildings are
to be retained for agricultural use
there's no access to them what is at the
moment the existing where you can see
the black car is parked as a shared
agricultural domestic access and that
would remain as existing so you can see
that hard standing curves off to the
right hand side that's the access into
those bonds existing and proposed thank
you no you're going obviously this is
fundamental about the Greenbelt aspect
now then what special circumstances are
you saying that we should take into
consideration on this thing as opposed
to considering all the other elements in
the officer's report
so the fundamental aim of the green belt
is openness and looking at slides five
and six you can see that with the extent
of demolition there's 28 buildings to be
demolished on the site openness is
certainly achieved and more than that
it's not that all of the land will be
incorporated into a domestic use there's
a large area in the top right-hand
corner which will be reverted to
grassland but added to that if your
policy cs10 on Greenbelt in terms of the
development management considerations it
talks about a replacement building must
not be materially larger than the one it
replaces taking into account any
buildings that are to be removed as
they're taking into account any
buildings that are to be removed now
your officer has interpreted that and
she said it's her interpretation as that
should just be domestic buildings or my
interpretation of any buildings is any
buildings and therefore the agricultural
buildings which are to be removed are
part of the very special circumstances I
think we like brings up with technical
questions through the office in a few
moments I'm sure should be ready for
that particular could you go to slide 6
again please could you go to slide 6
please okay I think the argument you're
looking at down on this from from up off
the upper berth I see your point about
the openness but looking at it from
ground level I think that's Linkwood we
need to have a look at or or examine
ourselves button to make a judgment on
all right council Richards Thank You
Joan I'm glad you talked about the
removal of buildings etc because that's
where I was coming to I hadn't realized
quite the amount of buildings that were
gonna be going your force base
calculations are based on all the
buildings on site now so all the
buildings that are on site now versus
what would be on site if we this would
be granted is that correct
yeah um for my sins I'm an accountant by
trade got the reduction in volume of 28
percent 30 pro and those are taking all
of the buildings on the site into
account the increase in volume of 52
percent that Jane quoted was just
looking at the brick built joined up
pieces that they're at the moment that
apart that could be part of a normal
barn conversion with the existing house
so those percentages if you mean the
ones where it grows in size it's taking
the top top piece which is the existing
farmhouse okay I understand I understand
that thank you I'm just from my benefit
can we get to number five and just on
there so I'm clear it's the main
farmhouse the brick part down the middle
there's sort of two bits sticking out
back and then that one piece yeah well
that that's so taking that volume
calculation adding on the extra you
worked out and then if we remove
everything else then it's minus 28 okay
thank you
how's it filming the bonds you've got to
the right of the professor if we go to
six please they seem to be right up
against the building is that the case or
is there a passage between the two the
buildings there's a person's wet between
the two so if they are used for
agricultural or livestock is it not
going to cause a problem with regards to
the residents well they are in the
applicants ownership so if the land is
rented out to a farmer who has livestock
than the applicant is clearly in control
of that situation it may be that the
land is arable farmed and machinery
could go in there but it's in the
control of the applicant Casavant
but no internal Mossad did it was a nice
some of the old house and some of the
barn but there are nice bricks in the
plan that we've got utilizing the barn
or is it a completely build because I
wasn't sure by looking at it whether
there was any bits of it there was
stables at the back there was pig places
at the back all brick and they're all
going are they the majority of it is its
new build but if you see the right-hand
element where the mouse is at the moment
that's what a t-shape that is existing
to be converted so will be reused brick
so the old barn
the main threshing barn that you saw is
being retained and converted as part of
the scheme okay thank you very much
Raskin soon they may get an increased
allowance of us stay longer chairman I'd
like to retain use of a number of the
slides which have been shown that is
slide number two and then I will call
for slide number seven and slide number
four and I hope that hasn't evaporated
any of my five minutes but I'd like to
start with slide number two which is
there one of the or the interpretation
which the officer has made on cs10 and
particularly Section B is that all any
building on the site is looked upon as a
domestic building this actually in the
wording is not the case it does refer to
a general impression of buildings on the
site so the interpretation I believe is
that any building there can be removed
for the benefit of development on the
site
I think reading it it seems to me that
that is certainly the case without any
doubt
and certainly the removal of the
redundant buildings will make a massive
improvement to the Greenbelt to its
openness and any other benefit which one
wants to associate with it certainly
with neighbors it's not an isolated site
as if it were standing alone in the
country it does have a number of houses
bang opposite to it and that is why the
residents there are so keen to see some
improvement to this particular site
because it is as you can see from there
and certainly from the visit a
hotchpotch of structures which are
corrugated which have made of wood and
rotted wood as that so this development
will be an enormous benefit now the
previous application was objected to by
a good number of organizations certainly
CPR II they are absent on this occasion
so I certainly look upon that as an
endorsement to the proposal but
committee were quite concerned about the
situation that what was then proposed
had no reflection of what a Warwickshire
style farmhouse would be with courtyard
design and approach that I believe has
now been well and truly satisfied with
this new application could I turn now to
slide 7 please now it is as you can see
here the blue are the redundant built
agricultural buildings which are to be
converted and amalgamated into the new
proposal and as I've said previously
cs10 section B refers to buildings
it doesn't say domestic or housing
buildings and my belief is that the the
modal bluish type buildings there
which are the redundant agricultural
buildings do qualify for incorporation
in any volume calculation the existing
house plus barn shows the dimensions
there as well as the proposed house and
redundant bonds now acknowledging what I
say the percentage increase in volume
for the new development would be 53% for
for proof floor space 28% and for
footprint 38% now the Greenbelt
obviously is a very sensitive area but
we have seen applications process
somewhat appeal and some at this
committee where volumes of that nature
have been increased a few years ago
there was one at appeal where the volume
of increase was 78 percent and this
committee for property and broad laying
term with an Arden actually passed
against officers recommendation to
refuse a volume increase of 105 percent
so the volume factor here is certainly
very containable and with the
incorporation of the bonds of the volume
is well within acceptable proportions
could I move on to slide 7 channel
please sorry I pick apart and for for
this is the completed situation which I
think by any stretch of imagination one
can only say what an improvement on the
current situation which quite frankly is
so Tati it is something which Deborah
gates the Greenbelt it has no
preservation for it this enhances it it
stands as a more traditional water to
bond with the courtyard seconds
councillor everything else to go with it
I think one comment in the application
or offices is that it's not sustainable
I believe it is on the both three of the
qualifications for since sustainable
development it is economic because of
the constant
and the reinstatement of agricultural
buildings where it is good to preserve
what exists five seconds please cancel
social and it is environmental it
certainly is a well-designed house it
improves the Thank You Council approves
the openness and I hope members will
accept that importance of the applicant
Thank You chairman now is there any
questions you'd like to ask the
councillor thank you very much cancer
cousin right
yes cancer which is a clarification
point please could you have slide two
for me and can you see on the red brick
there's two bits of the building
sticking out other side narrow it down
down down down that one and that one
I may have overlooked this in the first
first this are they been knocked down
and replaced or they've been joined up
right I think we clarify the difference
between 53 and 250 percent increases on
the thought news so could you please go
over that one for me and I've looked at
the proposed dwelling in relation to the
existing dwelling and and that produces
a volume increase of two hundred and
fifty two percent and I've also looked
at if the outbuildings were not to be
converted and were to be removed from
the proposed dwelling that would still
be a percentage volume increase of 160
percent okay so are only talking about
the actual dwellings the building's not
the farm buildings at all we're not
talking about those enemy in any way no
no that's not relating to the farm
buildings okay
Casavant I don't know whether you can
answer the question but I did you're on
the side business in the properties that
are there obviously aren't fit to living
if we were to grant this what is the
conditions or as there is no conditions
about materials because there were two
beautiful bricks in that but what I saw
in my eyes I wondered whether I could
ask the question about materials at this
particular point if you will remind you
to grant permission and we would put
condition on requiring submission of
material samples obviously the parts to
be converted would be retained in their
existing bricks
can we put any conditions honestly would
you approve it that they are similar or
like the one was a honey borne brick see
the barn was made of only born brick yes
we would be looking at bricks to match
as closely as possible to the existing
that's Richardson councillor fielding
thank you sir I did over the second
question before but my realization that
to the most beautiful parts the building
being knocked down my disappointment
might make me forget it
am i right in thinking that there is
policy that allows the conversion of
agricultural buildings such as those to
dwellings and that simply notification
process not for planning application
there is a class Q permitted development
right and I've not assessed it against
the court the procedure for that so I
don't know if it would qualify it may
fail I think there's a caveat someone
might correct me if I'm wrong there's a
caveat that can't be a classic oops
within the curtilage of a dwelling I
think some of this would forward in that
so okay I mean that's something that I'm
aware of and I just wondered whether it
had been right up clearly it hasn't been
so we can't really make an assessment on
whether it would or wouldn't be but it's
certainly something we should be aware
of if we were minded to grant permission
do we have the ability to remove for
future PD right on the entire site yes
we could put condition on removing PD
right thank you
just following on from canceled answers
comment on materials the roof there on
the house is probably rosemary or pan
tile roof going to the number slide for
its changed to slate is there something
that would be acceptable or do can you
make sure it remains the same as the
rest of the buildings again we can
condition requiring samples to be
submitted and agreed so there is an
opportunity for alternative materials to
be considered any other technique
commissioners I just want to clarify
please I'm sorry I keep going over this
on the difference how can it be so
different from the the agents per spends
a percentage increase to to yours I just
need to get clear in my mind why is it
so different
obviously we can't be fully sure there's
clearly two different figures in play
here one possibility is the way that is
the approach towards what is the
planning unity and officers have looked
at this has been the planning unit
formed by the dwelling and it's
curtilage and taken into account only
the buildings that forward in that we
consider that the right approach because
policy cs20
the title of the policy is existing
housing stock and buildings which
suggests is talking about the house and
its curtilage rather than any further
buildings which may or may not come into
play when you're looking at very special
circumstances further afield so that's
probably the best I could offer on the
disparity between these figures that's
okay thank you yes Richard sorry I know
I can't come out with new questions and
the the impression I've just been given
from this check that the pitch the views
of the building with a different colored
slate roof is it's potentially that the
whole thing's been knocked down and
rebuilt is that the case or is it the
existing farmhouse is just being
repointed and made structurally sound
with the addition of the sub it's on the
side the building is being demolished
and rebuilt apart from the outbuildings
to the side which form that T shape
being retained yeah that makes more
sense it's not listed then obviously all
right okay I'm there Thanks I think you
like clarification I mean I didn't pick
that or not myself okay and counsel
Jones did you only go into debate or do
you want to technical debate
oh sorry classic Aries did I miss you
out there
okay okay open to debate counsel Jones
first then Kasich energy the arguments
been made that's a very special well
there has to be very special
circumstance here because the reasoning
in this report is very clear this
replacement dwelling is significantly
larger and therefore it's inappropriate
development in a Greenbelt frankly I'm
not sure it matters what the percentage
is because both all of those percentages
it indicates it's significantly larger
it's obviously significantly larger and
so therefore you need very special
circumstance the main one that's been
pointed to is essentially the sites
going to be tidied up you will
potentially have some buildings removed
so on so forth well it's a very logical
point made in the report which is if you
have an appropriately sized replacement
dwelling you will still have the benefit
of the tidying up of the site and the
removal of those buildings so that is
why that is not does not count as a very
special circumstance because that
tidying up of the site can happen
together with the proposal for an
appropriately sized replacement dwelling
I have to say I'm not sure it's I don't
know that it's a reason that could be
added to the refusal and and I wouldn't
you know I wouldn't necessarily say it
if I do I actually do think it's a bit
disappointing that not more of the
building that is there is converted
rather than demolished and maybe that
feeds into this business about the
science because actually it is a
beautiful building with and it might not
be listed but to me it has some
significance and for me personally I
think that is a disappointment but as
far as I'm concerned the reasoning is is
strong and solid in that report it's in
accordance with policy I think should be
careful about setting precedents that
and being consistent with our policy and
so for that reason I would propose
refusal in accordance with the
recommendation made in the report cancer
carriage oh this is great I find myself
in complete agreement actually with
everything you've just said it's very
clear in the report it's complicated but
quite clear with a fair wind given the
most the most lenient
look policy we should really be doing
it's still 160 percent bigger you know
that's and that's you know that's giving
it a wink so it is significantly larger
this is green belt it needs very special
circumstances yes it's a lovely new
build but it's a massive new build and
yes the site has tied it up and yes
there is less volume overall perhaps but
they are very old farm buildings this is
a very big house as bait great
difference between a very big house and
a lot of little from farm buildings in
the Greenbelt and I second that proposal
thank you
the the buildings all the house that's
currently there any idea when it was
erected it sort of 1898
alternate century if so how they guessed
about 200 years councillor and it would
be a pity to lose something of that age
and also the steam councillor vans refer
to the the brickwork and the use of the
brick and everything else surely there
can be some sort of joining up of the
existing house into what is proposed to
the present moment I'm very much on the
on the edge of whether to approve or not
I agree with counselor Atkinson that
it's it does tie to the site up and it
does look a big improvement but I think
it's a pity that we're going to pull
down the existing house Catherine okay
thank you so I've swung from one end to
the other about four times journalist
this hearing this entire conversation
had this been the reuse of the existing
building and
restructuring of existing barn buildings
I think I'm probably more likely to have
swung in favor of granting having now
discovered that it's not that it is
actually a complete demolition of what I
consider to be a extremely beautiful
building granted needed a bit of TLC but
an extremely beautiful building
nonetheless I'm actually now moving to
are very much on the side of refusing in
line with the officers recommendation I
think what Cancellara said is absolutely
spot-on that had this been the reuse of
existing buildings so the redesign of
existing buildings then I think I'd be
much more palatable but it's not and
therefore I will be going with the
officer recommendation refused thank you
I do get the tidying up the site I
really get that I do like the new design
I really like that then fortunate thing
was that again that has now just come
out and think that question is literally
the the complete demolition of this is
area and again that ducktor sort of hurt
I don't really like that again I I can't
fill I still have my problems about the
green herb mr. green but I am partially
swayed by that argument but it still
will be a significant increase in the
volume and hugely whatever weed
whichever way it goes
so I'm afraid I'm going to also go with
the I'm afraid I'm going to go with the
officers recommendation cassabaum I I
did go on the side visit I did like the
barn I don't think the rest of the
buildings are in my eyes in a position
now though I'm not a builder to really
there were very very small rooms in the
big old house bloke had been in there
hundred years and that untouched it's if
you want to believe that way I did like
the barn as far as I'm concerned it can
be a new build if the bond is kept
but unfortunately the barn isn't there's
enough that
oh well the point being is that the
resilient brick buildings around the
original house that peak sized the
stables and that which could have been
accommodated for like we said be use
which is agricultural chain with the
with the hot with the height of the with
the height of the wall being over two
meters is what the rules are
I've got a number in my area so I think
we're nearly there in my respect but and
this is a tidying up operation it was a
you know if you like a tip is not the
right word probably but has just just
been grown and left most of the
buildings were not usable for livestock
now under those conditions except the
two big barns we take on a key which we
went in which were had been used for
lambing so as far as I'm concerned I'm
really there in the respect of tidying
it up the barn they say is being kept
the house to me wasn't suitable for for
renovation is the probably right word so
I think we get in there I think that
before I asked us Allison about the
demolition because she obviously said
that it was being demolished and one
thing I didn't say while I was speaking
is that I don't believe that special
circumstances have been demonstrated on
this side either so that's the one of
the reasons but it was made so I wasn't
just quick one yes the bits be retained
is the threshing barn and the long part
that runs through to the front to the
rear and the rest of the existing
dwelling and all the parts of that has
to be removed and replaced
so this is this is to be retained the
buildings in purple
okay um members I still have the
recommendation for refusal a promo
proposal I stopped a second uh correct
remembers the event before you is to
refuse prior information seventeen - OH
- 5.9 / for all those in favor
I've Chen against to chair this
committee therefore results to refuse
planning permission for 17025 99004
thank you thank you very much council
bonds I appreciate right so okay that's
perfectly acceptable coming around for
dinner then thank you right our last
item on the agenda this evening is 17 /
double 2 7 9 / 4 and our presenting
officer is Richard thank you
Thank You mr. chairman this application
is it clear well house Whitley he'll
hand in Arden as you can see on the os
plan here hopeful you can see that
clearly it's located about a mile east
of Henley on the Warwick Road
just as you come out of the settlement
of Henley moving in a bit closer this is
the site here on the north side of that
road relatively large plot with the
detached dwelling located there and this
just shows an aerial view to give an
idea of what that looks like the
proposal before you tonight is the
erection of a detached garage or the
games room above and these slides show
two separate proposals the one at the
top in this position here shows a
planning permission that was granted
last year for effectively the same
garage that is now proposed it was
granted in that position here so to the
side of the detached dwelling the
application before you tonight proposes
to relocate that building to this
location here so further away from the
dwelling and turning it through 90
degrees
so this is a photograph stood within the
site looking northwards sorry
no it's looking thank you looking
westward so that's actually the front of
the house and the the Warwick Henley
roads just off to the left here behind
the hedge and then the final photograph
he's looking south towards where the
proposed garage would go which is in
this area here behind that hedge is the
main road nothing further to add to the
report thank you just a clarification
the previous application was a delegated
that was based upon it was based on
obviously the same proposal that
proposal was within five meters of the
dwelling and it was treated in Greenbelt
terms as an extension to the dwelling
rather than an outbuilding thank you
right thank you our first speaker in
fact our only speak this evening is mr.
Andrew Firth under your two three
minutes if you could in your own time
just press the button at the bottom of
microphone and you go thank you thank
you very much ladies and gentlemen and
my name is Andrew Firth and I'm the
owner of clear well house I did just
want to say because councillor Lawton
was going to speak in in favor of this
that we do have no objections from the
neighbors or from the parish council and
indeed councillor Lawton was going to
speak in favour but unfortunately
couldn't make it this evening and his
reasons were that he felt that the
change had was actually less visual
impact and less hard surface and that
there was no impact on the openness of
the Greenbelt I'd like to sort of
further those points really by saying
that this is a property our property
we've owned it for 15 years and we've
invested significantly in
trees and the mature gardens and we are
very committed to the green bells if we
could go to the next slide the proposed
reciting you know I think the key the
key points that make is that we're not
making any changes at all to the
building but by moving it through 90
degrees we make 95 meters squared of
less hard standing so less footprint and
only thing that is better for the
Greenbelt actually I don't agree that
it's really then separate from the house
is still really part of the curtilage of
the building and I don't think there's
any more visual harm indeed I don't
think there's any visual harm just to
the next slide just to clarify we are
swinging the building through 90 degrees
and moving it 10 meters from the house
rather than 5 meters and that's just to
give us enough space to use the drivers
we want to use it and I think it does
actually create a better configuration
as a sort of courtyard moving to the
next slide this is the view out of our
living room looking West and if we do
build it where it's currently permitted
it would be literally straight outside
that window which would really be not so
nice for the light coming in and the
next slide shows you the proposed site
which you know I think it if you look in
the background you can see the the next
door property so actually the next door
property which is on the road is just
that it's just over the hedge if you
like so it's not really having any
impact on the way that the buildings are
configured moving to the next slide this
is just something I googled to show what
a Warwickshire courtyard looks like and
I think we will be able to create a
courtyard effect by moving the garage to
perpendicular it'll allow us to create a
much nicer courtyard effect rather than
a linear effect and the next slide just
shows the seconds belief really there is
no impact on the road side at all
because of the greenery that we've been
growing for the last 20 years all around
here final slide really is just to say
there's no precedent being set here on
the one side of the house so we have a
neighbor that's already
to garage this perpendicular and on the
other side the the nether a neighbor is
right on the roadside and the final
point is just just to say that that we
one of the conditions was a removal of
permitted development this used to be a
small holding with a lot of our
buildings and we really would struggle
without permitted to development to be
able to maintain and improve their side
okay thank you thank you
you mentioned the hard standing I think
you said 90 meters squared 95 right -
squared 95 yeah less standing is it fair
to say that if there's 95 meters squared
less hard standing that's 95 meters more
garden or am i misinterpreting that yeah
it's more garden so if you look at the
picture on the on up now we keep all of
that lawn that I was showing you out
through the west of the house up on
there so to the west of the house is
currently a nice lawn that carries on
being lawn under this proposal and yes
there's 95 meter squared more grass kept
by the new position they asked we didn't
it was a sort of compromise met the the
planning officer and my architect
negotiated that and and and achieved
that that's where they got to last time
they discussed it and then when we sat
down with our architect and actually he
showed us what it was going to look like
we realized that it just wasn't really
going to work so it was just sort of
compromise between our architects and
the planning officer first time around
that once we saw it we realized it was a
mistake thank you I do appreciate those
lovely garden you've got there obviously
an awful lot of work in there so what is
the use of this building could you just
explain the use of it the use of this
building yeah it's just a triple garage
so gives us more space to park cars so
they're not left on the drive in
particular we want to move to electric
cars so we need charging points which we
can't get charging points where we've
got the current drive thank you very
much thank you that's fine if you guys
press the button on the microphone don't
appreciate it thank you
right um questions for technical
questions Katz Richard thanks
so we've granted permission for a garage
I'm struggling to understand why we
wouldn't continue to grant permission
for a garage when it's just been turned
round slightly it's to me it makes no
difference to the openness of the
Greenbelt whatsoever it all relates to
Greenbelt policy and Greenbelt policy
paragraph 89 the MPP F on our own policy
cs10 stake that all new buildings in the
Greenbelt are inappropriate so that's
the starting point those policies then
go on to list exceptions to that and one
of the exceptions is extensions to
dwellings and in the explanation in our
policy it also extends to allowing
outbuildings as long as they're within 5
meters of the dwelling so it gives
occupiers it recognizes the occupiers
may wish to have outbuildings so it
gives them that exception if you like
through Greenbelt policy which is why
the first application was acceptable it
was effectively treated as an extension
and therefore it was an exception to
being not inappropriate so it was
appropriate the current application is
different in that it's further away and
therefore it's treated entirely is an
outbuilding not an extension and
therefore there are no exceptions to it
meaning it's nothing meaning the disease
inappropriate and therefore needs very
special circumstances unclear they had
they had what's been proposed and and
granted been built then we could be
looking at an application to put that
there that could be deemed as an
extension to the building that were
there and they're not
one down then would be ended up in
exactly the same position you mean it
would be within five meters of water
pretty nice that's been built let's say
for argument's sake we're looking at
that top bit there that's actually
insert you another application comes in
to put as an addition a bit underneath
leaving that in so that becomes in there
you build something here yeah yeah so we
could do that because that would be
deemed to be an extension and then
someone come back and say well actually
I've quite like to knock that down
because it's I would say that wouldn't
be an extension to the dwelling house it
would be an extension to an outbuilding
so it would be increasing the size of an
outbuilding so I think that would be
inappropriate so what you think it's an
extension on the extension yes extension
yeah it's still an outbuilding but it
gets an exemption because it's viewed as
an extension for the policy it doesn't
change the fact it's still an
outbuilding but there's that exception
made to allow people to have
outbuildings otherwise all outbuildings
would be inappropriate understand I
think also we can sever it as we need to
just look at the Advocate application
before us obviously and I I get the
argument I fully get the argument but I
think it's a little on the tenuous side
okay then I shall open up to debate them
cancel jars
the applicant is you know I don't mind
or is it in a very compelling way in
many ways but I have to say I do
understand the reasoning in the report
you know the point is the original grant
is actually only allowed in very
specific and narrow circumstances and
it's because it's in line with the
current building it's seen its seen not
just because of its proximity to the
building as an extension to it and that
but that's also a major part of it but
also because of its placement it's read
as one line and you know and the concern
obviously is with this new thing
although it looks very as a very simple
switch actually what it becomes because
of its distance and location it reads as
a completely separate building and
actually you know and the problem is is
you know in anyone else's guard and you
say well what's the big deal but
unfortunately if you do own a house in
the green belt but they are that is the
policy and that is the rule so so
personally although I feel you know it
is you know it's a very strict decision
and I do have sympathy with what the
applicant says I I do feel if we're
going to interpret policy consistently I
think I think it's a fair and balanced
report catheters so I'm going to
disagree with counsel jars on this
actually whilst I accept that policy is
there for a reason I don't think this is
particularly against policy I do think
we it's arguable that their special
circumstances are that it's the reciting
of an existing building or permitted
building that has the benefit of opening
up the site for or opening up the area
of it within the green belt I feel that
opens up the site personally I don't
think it makes any significant
difference whether it's next to the
house or where it's been proposed to be
other than that it's less blocky
unless linear and so I would propose
that we do grant permission for this for
the resourcing let's engage with those
special circumstances well we'd have to
go through those in a few moments I
think I've got is also setting
precedence
because my concern about this particular
one would be but and now in future as
ten meters now but it could be 20 meters
30 we could add buildings anywhere in
the Greenbelt and we're not in
discussion between ourselves but the
point is that at the end of the day I
think that the the fallback position
which is the granted planning permission
is acceptable under policy that one
isn't and I can see the reason behind it
and I'm afraid I have to disagree with
you no I go with Casa jars on this
particular point yeah sorry Celtic area
first yeah I think it is it I think it's
actually very difficult this I'm
surprised how difficult it is it's a
garage and it must sound silly to be
debating it like this and I can see
where counselor Charles is coming from
and and I think it is a very well done
report and that is definitely one result
you can get from it and we talked
earlier today about sticking to policy
especially Greenbelt policy because it's
important I agree with that I think
you've got a look at the level of harm
and obviously it's it's small but it's
still hard so you will require very
special circumstances strangely if you
wanted to go against the officers on
this one and grant it
and I think councillor riches well I
would suggest that there was a fallback
position as part of that circumstance
you know something almost identical can
be done so as far as volume in the green
green belt nothing's changed I would
also say that there's an increase in
green space you know there's a reduction
in hard standing which is definitely a
circumstance and would go to the
related to the house is important you
know it's not stuck out in the middle of
the garden it looks like a courtyard it
looks like it belongs so the
relationship the new relationship of
this proposal to the house is a good one
and part of a very special circumstance
as well yeah absolutely I think you just
said exactly what I'm thinking just in a
slightly different way so I'm entirely
happier with those as special
circumstances just on your point about
setting a precedent we all know that
we're not setting a precedent because
the special circumstances are specific
to this site and so it's not a precedent
were setting I would also argue that the
this reciting of the garage is actually
in line with the building that is
already had its permission granted it's
no further away than the end of that
building so I don't think there is any
material difference in terms of its I
think massive jars in Council 40 I've
got one point among question one point
is a courtyard effect would mean the
proposed building is forward and the
building lines are essentially sort of
you know in line with one another yes
that's the word I'm tired so I'm not
convinced it's going to create a
courtyard effect I just actually
rendered actually I don't know what the
dimensions of this proposed building are
especially its height
I think I'm correct in saying coccyx
alto Giles that it is actually a game to
him above it counter jars Castle jaws I
said I think I'm correct in saying
there's a game to him above it as well
so it's gonna be a reasonable height to
the ridge at 6 meters its length
10.7 long by six three deep so it's six
meters to the ridge at what what's a
one-story house usually is there sort of
what would that you do you have
definitions for heights for one or two
storeys a greater depth in discussing a
lot tonight about light from windows
they've got the the so he was shown in
the picture the patio windows looking
out on the side of the house and where
that building is it must be as was
totally as we were told would affect the
light coming into that room
therefore by moving into where it is
it's maintaining the house from the and
the balance within the house and I don't
and I don't see any problem with with
leaving or allowing the the garden to be
what it is it is moving a building into
a corner which he's already got a hard
standing on a sound stand and I'll go
along with carriage and Richards on this
one I think just on that particular
point at the end of the day the
applicant came in and gained plan
permission put it in that location says
his obvious where it was going to go it
wasn't gonna go somewhere else it was
going to go there therefore it must have
been taken into account so again I can't
I can't accept the particular hukka
myself you know Castle Joel's business
as well about removal of permitted
development rights and say well because
what I'm a little bit concerned about as
well is if one did want to build a
little house in your garden in a
Greenbelt this would be a way to do it
in the sense that you apply first for
your extension and then you just argue
that it should just be slightly moved
round when actually it could to all
intents and purposes potentially in
future start to be used as a not an
extension building but someone living
there and I'm just wondering is there
any uh once that's built can it then be
could you then apply to extend the
extent
if you see what I mean so that's what
and I know there was a request in the
applicant to keep permitted development
right so and I'm just wondering how that
would interplay and yeah obviously if
it's one thing to be used as an
independent drilling that would need
planning permission in itself and it
would come before us again at that stage
that's not before us tonight obviously
sure your way well if this were to be
granted then that would depend on
whether you may permitted development
rights so just just so we clear
I understand fishermen development
rights have already been removed
I would part of my proposal would not to
be read to reinstate those permitted
development rights we removed on the
previous application but that's not been
implemented so hasn't bitten yet and so
they're still interrogating us in that
case I would like to maintain that
position so what I do think the
applicants intentions are honorable but
I do think it would be important that we
take that committed to voting right away
in order to first be able to brand this
in the same way that the previous one
only removed out buildings so there was
an option for members to remove
extension pd rights as well if they saw
fit so I might in my in my mind I think
it should be the same as we had
previously because ultimately this is
just a reciting of a previous
application cap security I think if
you're concerned if anyone is concerned
about PD rights you would want to
withdraw the extension rights as well
because we've moved the garage away from
the house which would enable an
extension to be built you know if it was
built where it is you can't really build
an extension because there's over there
that's that I think that's why I was
granted in the first place I've got no
problem with that
in my position is that we already have a
permission this is just a reciting of so
much time and position is that that it
should be the same as that if you if
members required that the removal of
extent
extension PD writes a mouthful now I'm
playing without to be part of proposal
ok are we saying that what are the
special circumstances that if we are
going to go along with this one if
councilor carriages councilor carriage
articulated than better than like listen
before that position being in existence
being you know almost identical the
increase in green space which I think
was a really important one because of
the repositioning and the relatedness of
and the functionality actually of even
this is a garage and and the relatedness
of this new situation to the house in a
courtyard style seems to be appropriate
plus the fact that this there's nothing
else against it in the offices report
yeah you couldn't even do that more
smoothly if you are saying the same
thing I did the way the proposed
building is related to the dwelling is
probably better than relatedness but
otherwise I'm entirely happy with with
what's been put forward and and it's
very specifically that they are to this
site only those are relevant to this I
only my advice is that all of those very
special circumstances could easily be
repeated elsewhere there are
circumstances that exist on this site
but it's they're not unique to this site
that could occur again I think yes on
this specific site at this specific
location and this specific size of
dwelling yes it's specific to this site
we're not talking about anywhere else
all right do I have a second on this
councilors Rich's proposal good
okay members under the vote before you
is to grant planning permission for 17/2
to seven nine five four
all those in favor one two three turn
all those against sorry chairman as
chairman I get the casting vote on this
particular point therefore I vote
against this so this motion fails
Council Giles can I propose we refuse
the application thank you and I will
second that so members the vote before
you is to refuse plane permission for
17/2 279 all those in favor 3 chairman
against 3 chairman and as chairman as a
vegetation who here I therefore will
vote against this and refuse plane
permission thank you very much indeed
and that wraps our proceedings for this
evening